[Musique]
téléspectateurs bien vous invite à y
aller comme toujours je reçois
aujourd'hui un invité hors du commun
deux fois lauréat de l'oscar du meilleur
réalisateur pour des films inoubliables
comme plateau n'a comme on peut le temps
presse alors maintenant qu'on fait moins
connu
il a aussi été décoré pour ses blessures
durant la guerre du vietnam qui a été
une source d'inspiration pour réaliser
certains de ses films je veux parler du
réalisateur oliver stone oliver
bienvenue et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
nous sommes pas vus depuis longtemps et
puis quelques années même très heureux
je suis très heureux de vous revoir vos
films remettre vraiment en question la
vérité officielle l'histoire des états
unis et montrent avec beaucoup de
réalisme
le caractère très dur des preuves comme
la guerre du vietnam
vous avez eu la liberté de réaliser ses
films de remettre en question hollywood
de lancer un défi à la vérité tel qu'il
est représenté dans les films américains
exactement vous vous êtes toujours senti
libre de faire ça non non la vie est une
évolution de mon père dans sa jeunesse
des républicains conservateurs
économistes à wall street
à metz il m'a élevé avec ses valeurs et
je pensais que c'était le seul monde qui
existait il appelait new york le centre
du monde
je suis né en 1946 à l'époque où les
états unis ont été la principale
puissance mondiale
il leur reste encore dans une certaine
mesure est prise il possédait alors une
richesse gigantesque et ainsi qu'une
vision du monde
égocentrique ethnocentrique soda soit
gloire pour être ce qu c'est là que j'ai
grandi et que je suis allé à l'école
mes parents ont divorcé quand j'avais 14
ans et j'ai continué mes études dans un
pensionnat
finalement je me suis retrouvé au
vietnam car je ne pouvais pas me faire à
ce système
je ne savais pas ce que je voulais
mais je savais clairement ce que je ne
voulais pas continuer à être le produit
de l'environnement d'un pensionnat de la
côte est des états unis et de yale j'ai
donc laissé tomber mes études à yale et
je suis allé enseigner au vietnam
j'ai rejoint la marine marchande et
finalement deux ans plus tard je suis
allé à l'armée ont déjà servi au vietnam
comme fantassin au plus bas niveau j'ai
voulu être au plus bas niveau et je me
suis retrouvé j'ai rejoint l'armée et
j'ai fait mon service j'ai passé environ
15 mois dans la jungle au sein du 25e
régiment d'infanterie et du premier
aéroportée au moment où j'ai terminé mon
service
j'avais déjà vu beaucoup de choses
j'avais adopté une approche différente
de la vie mais il me fallait retrouver
mon chemin je suis rentrée dans une
école de cinéma
j'ai cherché un emploi à new york
j'étais chauffeur de taxi j'ai fait un
peu de tout l'école de cinéma m'a
beaucoup pdg tourner des courts métrages
et finalement six ans plus tard j'ai
saisi l'opportunité d'écrire le scénario
du film midnight express qui a connu un
succès international
et comme ça à partir de zéro c'est un
des meilleurs films que j'ai vus
midnight express
vous avez écrit le scénario
oui j'ai reçu un oscar et caetera et
boum
soudain du jour au lendemain je me suis
retrouvée dans l'industrie
cinématographie même si j'ai connu des
hauts et des bas je tourne et platoon et
salvador vous connaissez sûrement ce
film fut j'ai tourné wall street
né un 4 juillet jfk après avoir tourné
trois films sur la guerre du vietnam
je suis passé du thème de la guerre à la
réalisation de trois films sur les
président américain john fitzgerald
kennedy
nixon bush en 2008 et j'ai aussi décidé
de m'essayer au genre criminelle avec
tueurs nés your turn et d'amour j'ai
tourné un film sur snow donne un film
sur wall street un film sur le football
américain voulant faire du dimanche
alexandre qui portait sur l'histoire
antique les sujets qui m'intéressent
sont très variés j'ai tourné alexandre
en 2004 et le montage ultime a été
terminée en 2014
la version finale est la seule que
j'aime vraiment bref j'ai eu une
carrière assez actifs matures
puis je me suis consacrée aux
documentaires les documentaires
m'intéresse de plus en plus car grâce à
eux
j'apprends plus de choses sur le monde
j'ai interviewé castro trois fois et
puis je vous ai rencontré quand je
filmais sa hauteur de la border en 2008
nous avons fait connaissance à cuba
quand j'étais avec raul qui nous a
présenté border est une oeuvre qui m'a
ouvert les yeux parce qu'à l'époque
chavez était le centre le maillon
principal
il nous a présenté à tous les dirigeants
frileux nous avons rencontré lula
nestor kirchner cristina kirchner hugo
paraguay vous en équateur et à cuba ue
et dagoba de l'abolir traiter une riche
expérience adema j'ai essayé une feuille
de coca avec evo morales ça a été une
expérience merveilleuse et je suis
retourné en bolivie avec hugo chavez
c'était incroyable de le voir assister à
la projection du film sa hauteur de
border vos oeuvres ont été très
critiqués mais nous allons y revenir
j'aime bien sûr je voudrais aller un peu
plus loin sur la façon dont votre vision
et votre vie ont été transformés par
votre dure expérience du vietnam oui oui
je pense qu'elle est au vietnam et voir
l'armée américaine se battre a été pour
moi le tournant
mais alors fallu non moins honnêtement
je ne pouvais pas en croire mes yeux
comme si une ville entière avait été
transféré dans un autre pays avec des
bases militaires géant une quantité
énorme incalculable d'équipements qui
d'ailleurs sont restés au vietnam
nous les avons simplement démontée en
pièces de rechange et la plupart d'entre
elles sont finalement tombées entre les
mains du soi disant ennemi
les nord-vietnamiens nous avons
développé tant de technologie crée tant
de départements différents
nous avons transféré le mode de vie
américain au vietnam
ça n'a pas marché nous avions l'armée la
marine l'armée de l'air trois types
différents de troupes qui faisait la
même chose
leurs responsabilités se croisaient et
cela a entraîné un gaspillage énorme et
monstrueuse d'argent c'est un peu notre
passe-temps annuler deux américains un
système auquel nous sommes trop habitués
quand je suis retourné aux états unis je
me suis dit on ne peut pas faire la
guerre comme ça franchement je pense que
puisque nous avions décidé de nous
engager dans cette guerre stupide
nous aurions dû nous battre beaucoup
plus durement nous aurions dû y envoyer
des forces spéciales des commandants
comme opéré à ce niveau nous aurions dû
rester dans la jungle au lieu d'en
sortir pour aller laver ses vêtements ou
préparer le dîner qu'est ce que c'était
que ces idioties
il faut faire la guerre de manière dure
je crois que nous n'avons jamais tiré 7
après 2001 quand nous avons été attaqués
quand nos citoyens ont été tués quand
une chose aussi atroce est arrivée nous
avons encore réagi de manière trop
émotionnel la peur nous a rendu fou la
peur a commencé à guider nos pensées au
lieu de se dire l'afghanistan très bien
on va régler ça
c'est ce que nous avons fait au départ
nous avons mis un mois pour tout régler
un mois al qaïda s'est désintégré et un
mois plus tard il était en fuite
mais non cela ne nous a pas suffit et
nous avons décidé de déployer nos bases
militaires et notre armée régulière
l'armée de l'air et les drones un par un
et quand il n'y avait plus personne
contre qui menaient une guerre
nous sommes allés en irak les attentats
du 11 septembre n'avaient rien à voir
mais non comment est ce possible
si on a un ennemi des gens comme dick
cheney nous ont convaincus que nous
avions des ennemis dans le monde entier
et que nous devions mener une guerre sur
tous les fronts tous maintenant qu'ils
ont dit la même chose sur la syrie voici
quels sont les souhaits de nos néo
conservateurs si je peux me permettre de
présenter les choses ainsi
même si en réalité ce sont eux les
va-t-en guerre comme on les appelait
auparavant
les va-t-en-guerre ma carrière au cinéma
a donc souffert parce que j'ai parfois
dit des choses que les producteurs
américains n'aimait pas du tout ils ne
veulent pas voir ça on peut dire avec
assurance qu'hollywood a changé de
régime il ya désormais beaucoup plus de
100 sur l'armée et la cia sont toujours
présentés sous un angle favorable dans
les médias américains
vous mettez beaucoup en doutent
l'histoire officielle des états unis
vous êtes un grand critique du système
sécuritaire de ce pays et que vous
considérez vous comme une personne anti
système
oui il ajouté qu'est ce que cela vous
causent des problèmes aux états unis
bien sûr malaga latine un peu moi c'est
parce qu'on amérique latine on peut dire
que vous critiquez que vous remettez en
question mais on vous permet de faire
vos films vos documentaires mental lui
on me le permet mais il ya une censure
économique mais autrement dit si on ne
gagne pas beaucoup d'argent grâce au
film critique ne seront pas diffusés oui
on peut réduire couper le budget mais
disons que c'est ainsi
si on veut tourner un film où sera
critiqué l'armée américaine par exemple
sur l'histoire de la guerre en irak
l'histoire de la terreur qui a eu lieu
il ya peu de temps si on diffuse de
telles histoires on n'aura rien
peut-être que dans les années 80 lorsque
j'ai filmé platoon né un 4 juillet
heaven and earth
j'aurais pu le faire car le système
n'était pas aussi rigide rêve il y avait
encore des idéologies il y avait encore
l'union soviétique après l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique en 1991
la situation mondiale a soudainement
changé les etats unis ont commencé à se
sentir de plus en plus puissants comme
une force dominante dans l'univers et
ont commencé à agir ainsi de plus en
plus activement
ils ont déclenché des guerres en iraq au
panama et à la grenade puis ils sont
retournés en irak puis en afghanistan
ces événements se sont succédé une
guerre après l'autre c'est profondément
ancré dans la mentalité des gens et les
médias ont accepté ça
les etats-unis n'ont donc aucun parti
aucune force démocrate à l'exception des
petits partis qui se pose la question
pourquoi déclenchons nous ces guerres je
n'ai entendu aucun des principaux
candidats le dire à part un ou deux
démocrates
mais ils n'ont aucune chance de gagner
autrement dit hillary clinton et son
équipe tout comme joe biden sont aussi
militariste que les républicains dick
cheney mais il exprime de manière
différente
hillary clinton est un faucon en même
temps l' approche plus pacifiste de
donald trump qui se demandaient pourquoi
luttons nous contrôler russe a tellement
fait peur à l'industrie militaire aux
hommes politiques et aux médias qu'ils
se sont mis à l'attaqué avant même qu'il
ne devienne président ils ont continué à
agir ainsi dès le premier jour de sa
présidence
ils ont tenté de le compromettre vial
affaires russe l'accusant de collusion
avec la russie il s'agissait en réalité
de différends politiques intérieures
sous couvert d'une conspiration russe
cela remonte aux années 50 c'était une
folie du moins j'estime que c'était une
folie en fait peu importe qui occupe la
présidence cela ne change rien il existe
un système établi au sein du département
d'état et du ministère de la défense
comme l'avait dit vladimir poutine dans
une interview qu'il m'a accordée peu
importe qui est le président américain
[Musique]
si on regarde l'histoire du monde les
etats-unis sont sans aucun doute le pays
le plus prospère de l'histoire de
l'humanité dans l'histoire nous voyons
que de nombreux grands empires se sont
effondrés car il ouvre à de trop
nombreux fronts sans aucun doute et ils
ont également déclencher des guerres
qu'il était impossible de gagner qui
s'éternisait contre les ennemis qui ne
se rendront jamais objectivement trump a
beaucoup parlé mais il a accompli peu de
choses les sanctions contre le venezuela
ont commencé avec obama est exactement
la déstabilisation de la syrie
il a reçu pour cela le prix nobel par
anticipation avait objectivement trump a
beaucoup parlé et on a peu fait tandis
qu'obama par avait beaucoup moins mais
on a fait beaucoup plus en terme d'
ingérence dans les pays étrangers je
suis d'accord avec tout ce que vous
dites cela montre peut-être à quel point
les états unis sont fermés à quel point
ce pays est imprégnée d'une idéologie de
droite
à tel point qu hillary clinton est
considéré comme représentante des
démocrates
je ne peux pas y croire les démocrates
sont normalement opposé à la guerre nous
avons cru en la possibilité d'une
coexistence pacifique
nous avons cru en la détente dans nos
relations avec la russie
vous rappelez mais il ya toujours eu des
forces opposées à cette détente
j'ai du mal ay croire c'est à dire
qu'aux états unis il n'y a pas de
véritables forces de gauche
il ne s'agit que de partis de droite qui
luttent contre d'autres partis de droite
la seule différence est une différence
de degré par exemple trump est un
représentant de la droite il a fait des
choses terribles qu'il a par exemple
pris la décision de retirer les états
unis de l'accord de paris de l'accord
avec l'iran c'est regrettable mais le
pire est le plus dangereux et qu'il est
sorti de l'accord nucléaire
il a tout simplement menti à ce sujet
est ce que nous avons fait avec la
russie est tout simplement
catastrophique
nous exposons le monde entier au danger
d'une guerre nucléaire
nous sommes agressifs en développant de
nouvelles armes nucléaires cela ne se
terminera jamais la déstabiliser le
monde entier et on le critique pour son
manque de dureté
quand il a dit qu'il retirait les
troupes de syrie les démocrates l'ont
attaqué il voudrait qu'il leur donne de
bombarder la syrie si deux partis de
droite mène la danse
aux états unis il ne reste plus d'espoir
qui dirige tout qui contrôlent la
situation
c'est comme une sorte de magicien d'oz
s'il tient les rênes dans ses mains sa
main droite et sa main gauche mais celle
de gauche
ce sont des illusions j'ai voté pour un
autre parti en 2016 pour le green party
j'ai voté pour jean stein c'était un
vote de protestation
que puis je faire d'autre je vais faire
des films et documentaires les films que
vous avez réalisés sont déjà une grande
contribution non vous savez c'est un
grand apport à une prise de conscience
savez vous comment expliquer les
avancées des états unis depuis 1945 pour
livre c'est la plus grande
hypnose de masse de l'histoire de
l'humanité comme s'il avait écrit sur un
écran nous sommes pour la liberté
nous sommes pour la démocratie pour
l'enrichissement de tout le monde
voitures et ils vendent encore et encore
cette légende selon laquelle les états
unis sont le meilleur pays de la planète
alors que les faits prouvent le
contraire
énormément de personnes ont été tuées en
irak en syrie en afghanistan au vietnam
et en corée
des millions de personnes ont pu être
tuées de la manière la plus brutale
violente
du coup quand hillary clinton déclare
que les états unis constituent le
meilleur pays de tous les temps que nous
avons apporté plus de paix et de
prospérité à l'humanité que n'importe
quel autre pays c'est de la folie
si nous nous comportions plus comme la
suisse ou la suède si en tant que
puissance dirigeante nous agissions dans
une perspective d'éducation ces
problèmes n'auraient pas surgi le monde
serait dans un meilleur état
un bien meilleur état qu'il ne l'est
maintenant je pense à des problèmes
réels tels que la médecine l'éducation
et je dis toujours l'énergie l'énergie
propre sont des problèmes vraiment
importante
contrairement à cette farce
géopolitiques et aux déclarations selon
lesquelles les états unis sont menacés
par la chine la russie l'iran ou le
venezuela nous ont déclaré que le
venezuela
constituait une menace pour la sécurité
nationale américaine incroyable c'est
l'hypnose en action ça ne peut pas être
autre chose je vous hypnotise à partir
de maintenant vous allez croire au rêve
de la bannière rayé c'est du pur orwell
et ça marche c'est de la publicité les
pays qui résiste le plus fort à la
domination américaine
ce sont la russie la chine l'iran la
corée et le venezuela ces cinq pays sont
13 l'otan a commencé à élargir ses
frontières en 1999 combien d'autres pays
ont rejoint l'otan et tout cela a lieu
aux frontières de la russie
c'est une violation flagrante de
l'accord conclu à la fin de la guerre
froide une violation flagrante
les etats-unis ne sont dignes d'aucune
confiance et bien si nous parlons de
violation du droit international
on doit parler du blocus de cuba qui est
une atteinte au droit international des
sanctions contre le venezuela qui
constitue une agression bien sûr tout
cela n'a pas le moindre fondement au
regard du droit international
en passant les états unis abritent le
siège de la commission interaméricaine
des droits de l'homme mais n'ont pas
ratifié le pacte de san josé où la
convention interaméricaine des droits de
l'homme qui est la base du système
c'est là une profonde contradiction qui
devrait être considéré comme
insupportable mais qui en réalité est
presque banal
t'es citron combien vous avez fait un
documentaire sur sept présidents
progressistes d'amérique du sud
d'amérique latine plus précisément car
vous avez réalisé une interview du
président cubain
pourquoi avez vous réalisé ces
documentaires quel était votre objectif
et ouais c'est que l'amérique du nord
n'accordent pas d'attention particulière
à l'amérique du sud
je le savais au moment de tourner mon
film salvador en 1985 et 86
c'était un film sur la situation au
salvador j'étais conscient du fait que
cela ne les intéressait par ailleurs la
seule chose qu'ils veulent
blake fait d'avoir une cour arrière ne
peut pas laisser sa cour arrière être
détruite
la même chose a eu lieu dans le cas de
castro des larmes a violemment critiqué
de lui avoir tendu un
crohas de l'avoir laissé parler
ouvertement dans tous les sujets et il a
parfaitement exprimé sa position
c'était un homme qui savait exprimer ses
pensées très clairement la même chose
est arrivée au documentaire south of the
border absolument la même chose il a
tout simplement été ignorée par les
principaux médias
pour eux j'étais un ennemi un jour j'ai
été invité par le new york times les
rédacteurs m'ont demandé comment il
m'était venue à l'esprit d'avoir du
respect pour chavez
c'est là que j'ai compris qu'il était
impossible de gagner la polémique sur la
question latino américains les états
unis ont fort probablement organiser un
coup d'état en bolivie beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'ils l'ont financé ils se sont
débarrassés de vous ont fait d'énormes
efforts pour se débarrasser de chaves ce
qui s'est passé au brésil est une vraie
farce ce que l'on appelle l'eau faire
c'est à dire les actions militaires sous
la couverture du droit international ce
qui s'est passé en bolivie était aussi
du grand guignol et la situation au
venezuela avec le président autoproclamé
boyer deux ont reconnus par washington
oui mais tout cela est soigneusement
cachée soigneusement caché je
n'apprendrai rien sur la bolivie sans
regarder rt et malheureusement ils ont
interdit rt ils ont simplement exclu rt
des bouquets de chaînes télé ce qui
s'est passé en bolivie est absolument
honteux c'est clairement un coup d'état
est long mais il ya ce deux poids deux
mesures pour ce qui est de la morale
internationale
ils reconnaissent immédiatement le
gouvernement dé facto s'il est
compatible avec leurs intérêts c'est
évident je veux dire que à l'heure
actuelle la chaîne rte offre des
informations de qualité mais elle est
constamment ridiculiser je reçois des
informations déformées extrêmement
d'efforts mais je peux lire la presse
américaine mais tous les médias écrivent
toujours la même chose
d'accord je comprends votre point de vue
mais je veux aussi entendre une opinion
alternative
pourtant on n'entend pas l'opinion de
l'iran ou de la chine on n'entend pas le
point de vue de l'accord et du venezuela
ça ne nous est pas accessible c'est
scandaleux les gens deviennent de plus
en plus bête sous nos yeux
j'appelle ça l'hypnose de masse ils
contrôlent l'espace médiatique bloquent
l'accès à des informations alternatives
vous avez été très critique à l'encontre
des médias à mon sens le rôle des médias
est terrible et vous avez dit que les
informations étaient des informations
corporatives aujourd'hui
information obéissent à l'intérêt du
propriétaire du média depuis qu'on a
inventé l'imprimerie la liberté de la
presse est soumise au propriétaire de la
machine à imprimer
mais aujourd'hui le pouvoir a augmenté
parce que la cia a compris cela s'est
passé après la seconde guerre mondiale
la cia a commencé à participer à
pénétrer la sphère médiatique
ils ont nommé leurs agents ils ont
planté leurs agents dans divers journaux
magazines à la télévision leur influence
sur la télévision américaine a été
énorme ce qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre sympathisé avec la cia après le
meurtre de kennedy ne voudrait pas aller
plus loin dans ce sujet quand la
commission warren a été créé ils ont dès
le premier jour dit parfait c'est comme
ça que ça a eu lieu ils n'ont même pas
examiné les preuves qui sont apparus
quelques temps plus tard mais pour
revenir au sujet du brésil
ils se sont débarrassés de dilma
rousseff pour une raison purement
technique et cela montre clairement ce
qui se passe réellement
je crois que la sphère snowdon a joué
son rôle dans cette histoire je pense
que l'espionnage américain
je veux dire nous savons tous qu'ils ont
subis dilma rousseff angela merkel nous
savons qu'ils ont surveillé les
dirigeants d'autres pays mais n'ont
jamais par exemple
dilma rousseff a refusé d'aller aux
états unis voilà de quoi elle est
coupable elle n'a même pas exprimé obama
son mécontentement pour le fait d'être
surveillés ainsi peu importe que vous
vous opposiez d'une manière ou d'une
autre aux états unis ou non ils
s'occuperont de vous quoi qu'il arrive
quand ils ont décidé de s'occuper de la
compagnie pétrolière petrobras
ils ont mis en place une importante
surveillance tenez je suis sûr que
certaines de ces informations ont été
transmises au bureau juridique du
congrès brésilien et ils ont utilisé ces
informations pour compromettre dilma
comme ils l'ont fait avec lula de
manière générale ces cas de corruption
ne tue personne mais tu la réputation
des dirigeants de gauche il y à un
hachage médiatique et on leur route
ensuite leur liberté comme ils l'ont
fait avec lula da silva
lola pour conclure oliver voyez-vous une
alternative quelconque
avez vous un espoir d'assister à la
renaissance d'une vraie politique
une vraie démocratie américaine il ya
par exemple bernie sanders
il est un peu âgés mais il ya aussi
alexandria occasion cortese qui est
jeune lauréat
je peux seulement dire mais en tant que
personne qui a vu beaucoup de choses
dans sa vie que beaucoup d'américains
sont mécontents de la situation actuelle
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus mais
affirmé que nous pourrons créer une
organisation politique qui ait le
pouvoir et le soutien des électeurs
ce n'est pas du tout facile dans un pays
doté d'un tel système électoral dans
lequel vous n'êtes qu'un électeur d'un
état et il y a dix ans le 52 états par
exemple l'état du wyoming dans lequel
presque personne ne lit est représenté
par deux sénateurs l'état de new york
est également représentée par deux
sénateurs
autrement dit au moment où il compte les
voix votre voix n'a plus d'importance
le collège à doral au fond on met tant
d'argent dans la poche et ma voix mon
opinion ne peuvent pratiquement rien
changé il semble y avoir un accord
tacite
on achète les médias bhl de l'argent on
achète des candidats avec de l'argent
aujourd'hui pour qu'on les prenne au
sérieux les candidats américains doivent
collecter des milliards de dollars ça ne
marche pas il ya beaucoup de corruption
en amérique beaucoup plus que dans
n'importe quel autre pays du monde
on parle de la russie comme un pays
corrompu je crois qu'il existe une
corruption puissante aux états unis
c'est absolument incroyable c'est une
véritable hypnose de mars pouvait dire
aux gens que nous sommes en démocratie
mais en réalité c'est l'argent qui
gouverne on ne sait donc pas par où
commencer par quoi commencer
comment l'histoire se répète telle est
l'histoire se répète en effet tous les
empires s'effondre il ne reste plus qu'à
prier pour que cet empire pour que tout
ce mal parce que nous sommes lempire du
mal ce que regan a dit à propos de la
russie est tout à fait applicable aux
états unis d'aujourd'hui
alors je me suis dit ce qui est arrivé à
l'union sovétique va arriver aux états
et je pense que cela va arriver bientôt
dans le fasse aussi vite que dans le cas
de la russie
mais quelque chose va sûrement arriver
parce que nous avons atteint une limite
nous avons un effet dévastateur sur
l'histoire de l'humanité je dois dire
avec regret car j'aime mon pays que nous
sommes devenus une force du mal
nous sommes devenus une force du mal
pour les gens pour ceux qui veulent des
réformes pour ceux qui cherchent à
changer les choses qui est ok pour les
gens pour les gens pour les gens
ordinaires
1 et cela ne marchera pas je sais que
cela ne marchera pas il va y avoir un
retour de bâton
il ya une certaine force historique qui
régit le monde et si mon opinion
personnelle n'a pas d'importance si les
gens ne peuvent rien faire comme le
disait à son époque martin luther king
il existe au moins une sorte d'arc moral
de l'univers oliver merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation concret
[Musique]